this kid puts on quite a
show I have eyes on the target he does
not look all that
threatening looks can be deceiving your
highness are you sure you do not want
any backup n I'm great with
[Music]
kids you thought the story was over
but it was only just
beginning I don't do
sequels
normally but things have gotten a little
twisted in the
[Music]
Multiverse
who is this handsome
[Music]
dog
I've been looking for
you for a long time time time time time
time just be
careful I don't think I can bear to
narrate what might happen
next
Darcy we got a code red The Avengers
tower has been overtaken on Christmas
what is this Cod Air no wait Under Siege
no no no oh that's not it hey John mlan
[Music]
Focus